[Musique]
quelqu'un de sérieux blanc vieux
est-ce que vous savez qu'il y a des
élections sénatoriales ah non vraiment
je suis pas au courant mon Dieu non
est-ce que vous savez qu'il y a des
élections sénatoriales bientôt
absolument pas non du tout
non je ne savais pas je suis pas trop la
politique parce que je me reconnais pas
dans la politique
pouvez me Sénat à la charge de lire en
deuxième lecture les projets de loi qui
sont présentés au Parlement vous savez à
quoi sert le Sénat
le Sénat encore une bonne question
les députés ça repasse chez les
Sénateurs pour qu'il vérifie tout ça que
le rôle du Sénat vous semble aussi
important que le rôle de l'Assemblée
le député tout le monde connaît le Sénat
c'est pour 9 ans ces gens sont élus par
de grands électeurs donc les lecteurs le
combat des mortels il n'y a pas accès
c'est quand même l'Assemblée nationale
qui domine par justement le parce que
c'est une élection directe ce qui est
pas le cas du Sénat quel est pour vous
actuellement la coloration politique du
Sénat
et bien malheureusement plutôt à droite
j'imagine que c'est à droite par rapport
aux autres hommes politiques
quelqu'un d'un peu plus simple que
quelqu'un de plus abordable certainement
un peu vieux jeu quoi je trouve à mon
avis un peu vieux jeu c'est votre avis
madame oui moi je ne me coûte pas de la
politique plutôt
âgé d'un certain âge avec une barbe
quelqu'un de sérieux
et des grosses barres et des et des gros
ventre
vieux
et un peu ancré dans leurs habitudes
clientes enfin pas une super image
[Musique]